ce qui est délicat pour une personne en
situation de handicap
on peut le retrouver dans toute forme
d'ailleurs de discriminations ethniques
de genre c'est de se dire mais dès que
j'appartiens pas une sorte de normalité
qui est forcément subjective
il faut que je me plie à cette norme
donc il faut que je me plie à cette
majorité est donc là on rentre dans
trois cas de figure premier cas de
figure est ce que j'ose revendiquer ma
différence pour faire avancer justement
la société donc je me rend visible je
revendique mon handicap
deuxième possibilité je reste plutôt
dans l'invisibilité sociale je n'ose pas
aller vers l'autre je n'ose pas déclaré
nos handicaps
là ça devient vraiment important être
considéré pour une société qui se dit
inclusive connaître la personne aller
vers elle c'est le premier pas pour
vivre l'expérience de la reconnaissance
s'il n'y a pas cette connaissance ce
regard également se tait prouver
émotionnel ce face à face qu'on peut
avoir et que ces personnes là qu'on soit
pas justement à distance qu'on essaie de
la comprendre et bien je pense qu'on
pourra mieux agir derrière et ça c'était
je pense que c'est vraiment une une
importance fondamentale dans le cadre
d'une société que l'on appelle inclusive
tout ça c'est culturel
ça vient aussi de la manière dont dans
la société voile handicap en france et
c'est pas le seul pays on voit encore la
personne ensuite on est quatre comme une
personne diminué qu'il faut aider et le
temps qu'il n'ya pas cette acceptation
là que l'handicap fait partie de la vie
l'handicap si juste des personnes qui
ont des capacités différentes pas
forcément altérée juste différente et
bien forcément ça ça ça coincera